bitcoin's price is determined by supply
and demand just as the price of any
financial asset but what we know is that
bitcoin is a fixed supply asset as a
programmatic monetary policy meaning
that you don't actually have to
calculate what the supply potentially
will be in the future no we know with
100 certainty exactly what the supply is
today how much bitcoins coming into the
market and also what the future monetary
policy decisions will be it's all
written in code that can be analyzed by
anyone in the world and so ultimately if
you're looking at price all you have to
do is you have to forecast what demand
will be demand rises for a fixed supply
asset price goes up if demand falls
price goes down but one other nuance of
the evaluation of bitcoin's price is how
much of the bitcoin is actually
available in the supply for people to
come and purchase what i mean is that if
there's lots of bitcoin actually sitting
on exchanges then of course anyone could
turn around and with a click of a button
sell it into the market that's the
potential for a lot of cell pressure the
potential for the to push the price down
but if bitcoin's coming off exchanges it
means that people have gone they've
purchased bitcoin and they're taking it
into cold storage or taking self-custody
of it there's more friction for them to
go onto the exchange and sell it it
usually is a bullish sign and so what
we've seen over the last nine or 10 days
or so is the fact that about 54 000
bitcoin are actually coming off of
exchanges the beauty of bitcoin is that
we can literally see on the blockchain
that 54 000 bitcoin or so have been
taken off the exchanges this is the
balance across all exchanges for bitcoin
and as you watch this occur you can see
over the long term trend we continue to
see more and more bitcoin actually being
removed from these exchanges so if we
then take a look at the long-term trend
what we can see going all the way back
to january 2020 is that the supply of
bitcoin on exchanges has been falling
aggressively but they're circled on the
far right you can see that the recent
drop is a very very large drop in a
short number of days and so ultimately
as we watch bitcoin's price continue to
oscillate somewhere between 35 000 and
45 000 one thing to watch is how much of
the circulating supply is actually
available if demand increases but more
and more bitcoins being taken off of the
exchanges things should get very
interesting let's make sure that we're
all keeping an eye on this metric
because it could tell us what's going to
happen in the future hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time